- I'M TELLIN' YOU, VINNY,
NO DISRESPECT TO YOUR
DEARLY DEPARTED GRANDMOTHER,
BUT MY AUNT MAKES
A PASTA--FORGET ABOUT IT.
- YOUR AUNT LIVES
IN THIS NEIGHBORHOOD?
SEEMS KINDA DANGEROUS.
- WHAT ARE YOU,
MCGRUFF THE CRIME DOG?
COME ON, WE'RE LATE ALREADY.
- HEY, UH, YOU--YOU SAY
SHE LIVES IN THIS HOUSE HERE?
- [bleep]'S THE MATTER
WITH YOU, VINNY?
YOU'RE BEING RUDE.
LET'S GO.
- I'M NOT TRYING
TO BE RUDE, IT'S--
THE LIGHTS ARE OFF.
MAYBE WE--
LET'S COME BACK LATER. Y--
- HEY, SHE'S PROBABLY
JUST TAKIN' A NAP
AFTER THE HUGE MEAL
SHE JUST MADE FOR US.
GO IN.
- I DON'T HAVE THE KEY.
YOU SHOULD GO IN FIRST.
- OH, MARRONE, SHE SAID
SHE'D LEAVE IT OPEN.
VINNY, STOP BEING
SUCH A STRUNZ AND GET IN THERE.
- ALL RIGHT, ALL RIGHT.
- SURPRISE.